it's supposed to be a model of
coexistence
the port city of araka in the north of
israel
a place where jews and palestinians
usually live together
this should be the high season the port
should be buzzing with tourists
especially now most coveted 19
restrictions
have been lifted in israel but mahmoud
audi's restaurant is empty
his family has owned the business since
1972
and has a solid reputation
the clients don't return because the
image of the city is tarnished
our regular clients didn't come back and
it will take several months for them to
return
it's longer than we expected but since
the riots in may
at the start of the 11 days gaza war how
can this market remain
empty mobs of angry young people took to
the streets carrying out vandalism and
ransacking buildings
one person was killed moses afuta's art
gallery was damaged
he just reopened a few days ago but few
people are walking through the doors
he blames former prime minister benjamin
netanyahu
because the government didn't give him
education
they didn't put a lot of money the
government put money
only for stone they make like the big
poor they fix everything a museum and
everything
building they need to give you know
supporting to the people
that sense of neglect is something
knesset member ruth wasserman lende
heard about during her tour of this
ancient coastal city
an effort by the new coalition
government to be more inclusive
and i wanted to see with my own eyes
what is the uh
feeling amidst the people both arabs and
jews and
and what can be done to help and a lot
of the perpetrators were actually
underground people of crime
that are also making the lives of the
arab population within the city
very very difficult crime in palestinian
communities has risen during the past
decade
without much government intervention the
people are
you know are not satisfied by their uh
economical and the social situation
and they want
in every you know opportunity to
to you know to tell other people
please notice us we are here you are not
noticing us you are not dealing with us
you are ignoring us
for many arc is being boycotted as
punishment for the acts of a few
eventually tourists will start trickling
back
but for coexistence to take hold
palestinian grievances
need to be heard hamid al-jazeera
akka in northern israel